invencible inatajable e imparable esa es
y gaziantep la número 1 del mundo quien
hoy consiguió su segundo título en
roland garros lo hizo ante códigos de
eeuu en tan sólo dos sets 6-1 6-3 y una
hora 08 minutos de juego un partido en
que ambas jugadoras tuvieron que tomarse
su tiempo antes de poder meterse de
verdad en este partido pero fue
estudiante que quien logró hacerlo
primero quien logró finalmente plantear
el partido tal y como ella lo había
preparado para el día de hoy mientras
que la estadounidense de 18 años pues en
realidad acumuló demasiados demasiados
errores errores no forzados empezando
además con su servicio que es uno de sus
fuertes sin embargo la norteamericana
comenzó abriendo con una doble falta en
su servicio de juego en todo caso fue
gigante que ya en la segunda manga logró
finalmente igualar el 20 por el que iba
ya arriba el coco box y finalmente
terminar este partido sin a problemas
una nueva victoria entonces para la
número uno del mundo ya es su sexto
torneo que se lleva se lleva este año y
una victoria consecutiva número 35
igualando el rey de venus williams sin
embargo para correr las cosas no se han
terminado porque ella tiene mañana la
final en dobles junto a su compatriota
jessica peluda y ambas van a enfrentarse
a dos francesas kristina mladenovic y
karim garcía